[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN SEALES: Please
welcome to the stage
the entire cast of
Broadway's "Come From Away."
[MUSIC - COME FROM AWAY
ORIGINAL BROADWAY CAST,
"WELCOME TO THE ROCK"]
ALAN SEALES: All right,
that was amazing.
Give another round of applause.
That was awesome.
So full disclosure,
this is the largest cast
we've ever had on this stage,
so excuse all the chairs.
It's quite impressive, and
thanks to the tech crew.
So "Welcome to the Rock" was
the opening for that song.
What is the rock?
DAVID HEIN: The rock
is Newfoundland.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
DAVID HEIN: Newfoundland
is an island province
on the Northeast tip of
North America, in Canada.
And in 2001, they welcomed a
number of planes and passengers
because all the planes
were diverted when
the US airspace was closed.
ALAN SEALES: Right, OK.
So I want to get into the
timeline about this first.
But the four of you
who just joined us
after the performance, go down
the line here and introduce
yourselves and what you do.
DAVID HEIN: So I'm David Hein.
I'm one of the writers.
IRENE SANKOFF:
I'm Irene Sankoff.
I am the other writer.
IAN EISENDRATH:
I'm Ian Eisendrath.
I'm the music supervisor,
arranger, and conductor.
KELLY DEVINE: I'm Kelly Devine.
I'm the choreographer.
ALAN SEALES: Wonderful.
OK, so the timeline of
September 11th, 9:26,
FAA closes airspace.
12:00 PM, 18 planes--
Gander, the city
that this happens in,
was told 18 planes will land.
And then by 12:15, 13
additional planes had landed.
And then at the
end of it all, it
was 38 planes total, carrying
almost 7,000 people into--
came into a town that only
had 10,000 people in it
to begin with.
And they weren't even allowed
to leave the plane for hours,
right?
DAVID HEIN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So
getting into that--
as the writers, I think this
all begins with the two of you.
Why?
Where did you find this story,
and why did you write it?
IRENE SANKOFF: It was a
story that was suggested
to us by a friend of ours.
And we applied to
get a grant to go out
to see what was happening on the
10th anniversary of September
11, because a lot of the people
who had been stranded there
10 years before were going
to return because 10 years
later, they still felt so
much gratitude and so much
respect for the people
who had taken them in
and had become lifelong friends.
So we thought, OK,
there's going to be
all these ceremonies happening.
We need to be there
and just find out
why this place means
so much to these people
that they would come
back 10 years later.
DAVID HEIN: So we
traveled out there.
We, like Irene said,
we had a grant,
but we actually got to stay a
little bit longer to extend it
because the people
were there like,
uh, don't spend
money on a hotel.
Come stay with us.
Here's the keys,
just feed the cats.
ALAN SEALES: So they still
extended the hospitality
all the time.
DAVID HEIN: Yeah, we saw the
same generosity out there.
And we ended up
interviewing everyone
we possibly could
for hours at a time,
and we just came back with--
you mentioned 7,000
people on the plane,
there was around
9,000 people in town.
And we came back with
like 16,000 stories,
and we wanted to
tell all of them
and tried to do that in 100
minute musical with 12 actors.
ALAN SEALES: Well, OK, so I want
to take a step back, though.
The title, "Come From Away,"
what is a come from away?
IRENE SANKOFF: Come
from away is someone
who is not from Newfoundland.
So if you're not
born on the rock,
then you're considered
a come from away.
ALAN SEALES: And is
it like a New Yorker,
where after 10 years
and you get angry enough
you become a New Yorker?
IRENE SANKOFF: I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I think you could
have lived on a rock
longer than if
you had actually--
like than you've
lived anywhere else,
and you're still come from away.
Although apparently, David
and I are now honorary--
DAVID HEIN: There's
a ceremony that
happens in the show
called a screech in,
where you ostensibly become
an honorary Newfoundlander,
and that's happened
to us three times.
You have to kiss a fish, you
have to drink some drinks.
ALAN SEALES: But that's real?
DAVID HEIN: It's real.
IRENE SANKOFF: Oh yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Oh wow.
DAVID HEIN: So it's happened
to us three times and--
ALAN SEALES: You
kissed three fish.
DAVID HEIN: Yes.
Yep.
I mean, in the ceremony.
But at the end of
that, we were talking
to one of the Newfoundlanders
that we based the show on.
And I would saying, so, we've
been screeched in already.
We've been screeched
in three times.
We're Newfoundlanders.
He's like, no, you're
a mainlander still.
I was like, we wrote
a show about you.
ALAN SEALES: So
did the skeptics,
I guess-- when you were
trying to put this together,
were there are people
who were saying,
like, you guys are
insane to make a musical,
to write music or write
a story about this
and try to get it on stage.
I mean, was there
any adversity there?
DAVID HEIN: Yeah, I think--
IRENE SANKOFF: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, like starting
writing Newfoundland
and we were getting a tour of
the airport and the guy's like,
so you're going
to write a musical
about making people sandwiches?
Good luck with that.
DAVID HEIN: And
then beyond that, I
mean obviously, it's set against
the backdrop of what happened
here in New York on 9/11.
And we've been very clear
that it's not a 9/11 story,
it's a 9/12 story.
It's about the way this
community responded to it.
But also, we had a lot
of sensitivity to that.
We were living here on 9/11.
My cousin was in the towers,
but fortunately he got out.
But there was a lot of what
happened in Newfoundland that
resonated with us
in terms of-- we
lived up at around
122nd and Broadway,
at this residence for
international graduate
students.
So people from 110 countries
from around the world all
waiting for news, all
waiting for them to return
and supporting each
other as a community.
So there's something about this
international community coming
together to each other
that was familiar to us.
But also in the time
after 9/11 in New York,
it felt like there was--
the boundaries broke
down between people.
You could reach out to
anyone and say, you OK?
How are you doing?
And that's what happened
in Newfoundland.
I think that's what happened
internationally in many cities.
And it's something that--
what happened in Newfoundland
reminded us of that time.
It reminded us of how kind
we were to each other.
And so there's something
that really resonated with us
about the story.
ALAN SEALES: It's interesting
that what you just said
resonates with me, that
the boundaries went down.
Again, like your
morning commute,
going to and from work,
whatever, you're just like,
don't touch me,
get out of my way,
tourists pointing their
fingers in your faces.
And then you've got a whole town
of people here that just say,
screw it, let's let
all these people in.
They have nowhere to go.
They've been in
a plane for hours
and don't know
when they will ever
get back on, if they
will anytime soon.
So yeah, it was a
nice story to tell.
And then it went to--
you did a run in Toronto, right?
DAVID HEIN: Yeah.
So it was originally
workshopped in Toronto.
And then we took
it to Connecticut.
We did a presentation here.
ALAN SEALES:
Connecticut, really?
DAVID HEIN: Yeah, at
Goodspeed festivals.
And then we did the first
production with these guys,
with almost all these
guys in San Diego, which
was a co-production with
Seattle Rep, La Jolla
Playhouse and Seattle Rep.
We took it to Washington,
D.C. We took it back
to Gander for two
benefit concerts,
where all the proceeds went
back to local charities, which
was our way of giving back
to the community there.
And then took it to Toronto
for a full production,
and now we're here on Broadway.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
KELLY DEVINE: We've been
on tour for a long time.
ALAN SEALES: So I
was going to ask
Kelly and Ian, the two of
you, how did you get attached
to the show in the first place?
KELLY DEVINE: Uh,
musical genius.
IAN EISENDRATH: I was working at
the Fifth Avenue Theater, which
is a theater in Seattle that
does a lot of development
of new musicals.
And at that point, I
met David and Irene.
And we had a waffle
breakfast that
was the beginning
of our relationship.
It was fantastic.
We decided we could
eat breakfast together,
we could certainly
make music together.
And that was in advance
of the workshop.
That was when Kelly first worked
on the material, and Chris
Ashley, our director.
And they've been stuck
with me ever since.
KELLY DEVINE: I actually
saw their workshop
that they did in Goodspeed,
is when we first met.
I was working on another
show and we were neighbors.
Our houses were next
door to each other,
because you all sort of
live, all the writers
and collaborators
who live in a home
together for two weeks,
which is really interesting.
And so we'd see each other--
well, all of a sudden, you feel
like you're at camp together
with people you don't
know that well, but you're
like waking up in your
pajamas and you're like,
I'm going to brush my teeth.
It's just-- it's all-inclusive.
Yeah.
But yeah, so I saw
the show there.
And then I knew--
I thought the show
was very special,
and I particularly think these
two are really, really special.
We had a lot of fun.
And then Chris Ashley
called me, and I
had worked with him prior.
And he said, hey, I'm
working on this show called
"Come From Away."
And I was like, I
know "Come From Away."
I was so thrilled.
So yeah, that's
how that happened.
ALAN SEALES: So you're
the musical staging,
which isn't-- is that
different from choreographer?
KELLY DEVINE: You
know, it's funny.
That question comes up a lot.
It is and it isn't.
I mean, any sort of
musical staging to music
has choreography in it.
And I think the misconception
is that choreography is just
dance, like real dance,
like classical dance
that we're used to seeing in
like "West Side Story" would
feel like a big dance show.
And I think choreography
over the last 10 years
has changed into something else.
And a lot of time,
moving furniture
can be just as much choreography
as it is doing a triple turn.
And I think there's
a little bit of both.
They're really stoked
about the furniture.
They're really happy about it.
SPEAKER 1: None of
us can really dance.
That's why we laugh.
KELLY DEVINE: Now,
but you just blew it,
because everybody thinks you
dance beautifully in the show.
SPEAKER 1: That's you.
KELLY DEVINE: I get that a lot.
SPEAKER 1: That's all you.
KELLY DEVINE: Well, listen,
we worked on it together.
But yeah, there is
dance in the show,
and then there's also lots
of-- there's big transitions
that happen in the show
that are choreographed
within an inch of their life.
So that's sort of--
if that helps.
ALAN SEALES: Great.
No, I was going
to ask about that.
The cast here is we'll
say an experienced cast.
It is not a bunch
of college grad
stay up all night
whatever, you know,
burning the candle on both ends.
You guys are responsible.
You've honed your craft.
Have you had--
IRENE SANKOFF: Well done.
DAVID HEIN: Wow.
ALAN SEALES: Have you
had to tailor or--
I guess, how was
the choreography
influenced for this
particular set of individuals
for this particular show?
KELLY DEVINE: They're
laughing already.
I haven't even said anything
and they're cracking up.
Well, let's go the professional
route first, shall we?
OK.
So--
ALAN SEALES: First.
KELLY DEVINE: I would
say in all honesty,
it was really important that
this story feel very true
to Newfoundland
and to these people
that we are representing.
So that was the basis.
And they are real people.
You know, Newfoundland
is not filled
with professional ballet dancers
or classically trained dancers.
So it was finding
that movement first,
and then it was
working with these guys
to find what they do best,
highlight that, and then expand
on it.
And hours and hours
and hours of rehearsal,
and lots of hard work.
I mean, that's truly--
right?
That's what we did.
DAVID HEIN: It's really just--
KELLY DEVINE: You don't want to
know about the trial and error
part.
That was a long time ago.
That was ages ago.
DAVID HEIN: What Kelly
and Chris have done,
for anyone who hasn't seen the
show, for Irene and I seeing it
come to life is really amazing.
Because we wanted to tell
so many stories, what
these guys do on stage is switch
from character to character
on a dime, switch from
place to place using
only 12 chairs and two tables.
And so there's a lot
of moving furniture
that is choreographed there.
And it's this magic trick
that we never get tired of.
It's immediately a bus,
immediately an airplane,
immediately a legion hall.
And characters are
switching on a dime.
It's really-- it's
fun for us to watch,
and we've seen it
a million times.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I enjoyed it.
Now that you mention it
again, it's very seamless.
And you go cut back
and you're creating--
you're creating individual
scenes without ever changing
the set.
I mean, the set itself is fixed.
It's a one act set on
Broadway, which is very rare.
But I want to get Ian.
I'm confused about
musical supervisor,
or musical arrangements,
but then David and Irene,
you both are credited
with the music, as well.
So how did the music
collaboration happen,
and how did these credits work?
IAN EISENDRATH: You know,
it's confusing for every show
and every music department,
but Dave and Irene definitely,
they wrote the show.
They created the story.
They decided who would sing
when and what they would sing.
And I always think of my
job as the arranger or music
supervisor to get in
the trenches with them,
help to flesh out
specific moments based
on the work that
Kelly's doing, based
on what Chris is doing,
taking the words and the music
that they wrote, adding
even more texture,
putting things in the right
keys for various singers,
various moments, sometimes
extending things,
shortening things.
We have a group of 12
phenomenal actor-singers,
it's not your traditional
group of even spread of voices.
It's very much a unique
group of singers,
and I think we had a great
time in the room figuring out
what the vocal arrangements
are, like which
notes each person sings,
and really creating
a score that lives on them.
So I'd say Dave and Irene came
to us with like the ground
plans, the foundation.
And then our job, sort of
alongside with Chris and Kelly,
just like they
put it on stage, I
focused on coloring
in and filling out
what was already there, which
was just a great baseline
to build from.
And working really closely
with this group of people
and figuring out where did
they live, what notes do they
sing the best?
Stylistically, what
do they do the best?
I think something that's
really special about that show
and I'll be forever
grateful to-- these
are like 12 principal actors
who should all be singing solos
nonstop on a Broadway stage.
What makes this show unique is
you have these 12 people coming
together to form an ensemble,
very representative of what
happened in Newfoundland on that
day, all these people coming
from all over the world.
And they are singing
together and we
are feeling that power of
12 really strong performers
becoming one and sometimes
representing 15,000.
DAVID HEIN: And then and
then beyond just the vocals,
the music of the
show, the band--
Ian leads our
amazing band onstage,
which represents
Newfoundland music.
I grew up on that, and--
IAN EISENDRATH: you can
get a bodhran in there.
Yeah, we do.
Bodhran, fiddles,
accordions, bouzouki--
IAN EISENDRATH: A guy that plays
over 22 different tin whistles,
Irish flute, and pipes.
DAVID HEIN: It's really--
it's this traditional
authentic music,
but you put it on
a Broadway stage
and it feels unique and new,
and we've seen a lot of shows
and we've never seen
something like this before.
And then we layer on top of
that world music on top of it,
to sort of create this
musical metaphor of people
coming from all over the place
and contrasting, you know,
fiddles from Newfoundland
versus fiddles from Texas
or hand drums, bodhrans from
Newfoundland versus hand drums
from Africa, and
creating something that's
this layered metaphor for being
stronger together and coming
together.
And Ian's been responsible
for the arrangements of that
and leading it and learning how
to play button accordion, as
well.
IAN EISENDRATH: That's--
KELLY DEVINE: Those
were fun days.
IAN EISENDRATH:
Those were fun days.
KELLY DEVINE: When he was
learn in the accordion.
It was all the time.
IAN EISENDRATH: Kelly would
come up to me, Ian, stop.
I'm trying to stage a number.
But I'm trying to
learn this accordion.
ALAN SEALES: I like at
the end of the curtain
call the drummer runs
on stage, he's like,
hey, how is it going?
So the people, all
12, the cast members,
you are all phenomenal.
I want you to take a moment
and introduce yourselves.
And Kendra, why don't you start.
KENDRA KASSEBAUM: Hi, my
name is Kendra Kassebaum.
RODNEY HICKS: I am Rodney Hicks.
SHARON WHEATLEY:
I'm Sharon Wheatley.
LEE MCDOUGALL:
I'm Lee McDougall.
JENN COLELLA: I'm Jenn Colella.
JOEL HATCH: I am Joel Hatch.
CAESAR SAMAYOA Caesar Samayoa.
ASTRID VAN WIEREN:
Hi, Astrid Van Wieren.
Q SMITH: Q Smith.
CHAD KIMBALL: Chad Kimball.
PETRIN BROMLEY: Petrina Bromley.
GENO CARR: Hi, thank you.
Geno Carr.
ALAN SEALES: Geno's
Broadway debut.
Thank you guys.
IAN EISENDRATH: A
couple Broadway debuts.
KELLY DEVINE: Yeah,
we got a bunch.
ALAN SEALES: [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER 1: There's a
few Broadway debuts.
ALAN SEALES: Oh,
raise your hand.
Whose debut?
Raise your hand.
DAVID HEIN: All the Canadians.
ALAN SEALES: All the Canadians.
IRENE SANKOFF:
All the Canadians.
ALAN SEALES: OK, so we should
have you guys using the mics.
SPEAKER 2: The Canucks.
ALAN SEALES: Canucks.
The cast, Ian, you kept
mentioning like you had all
this cast and then you were
figuring out who sang where
and what was best, and who can
move and who can do a triple
pirouette and who can't.
IAN EISENDRATH: They all
can is what we learned.
ALAN SEALES: Raise your hand
if it's your Broadway debut
and you can do a
triple pirouette.
It sounded to me like as you
were telling the story a second
ago that the story, along
with the music and the books
and everything-- and
whatever that was--
and the cast was--
the cast came with the show.
How did the casting work?
I mean, how did you
find these people
and then say, oh, let's figure
out what we can sing with them?
Usually it's the reverse, right?
IAN EISENDRATH: I always
think it's interesting
the first time you cast a
new musical, because that
was really the first time
we were all in the room
together to even have
conversations about how are we
going to do this with 12 people?
What do they need to do?
Kelly has a specific
list of needs.
ALAN SEALES: Why did
you decide on 12?
DAVID HEIN: We started
out at I think--
IRENE SANKOFF: It
didn't start out at 12.
It went back and
forth a couple times
and we ended on 12, right?
DAVID HEIN: It was 14 initially
when we first started,
and I think partly we're
trying to tell so many stories
and we're Canadian, and there's
a very Canadian ethos of like,
well, I got a truck and I have
a church, let's put on a show.
So we figured we could probably
afford 12 people, maybe.
But also, there's
something really
wonderful about 12 people
portraying all of these people.
Every one of them plays a
local and a come from away.
There's something
that's sort of--
there's this great
metaphor underneath,
which is we're all the
same underneath it all.
And so there's something
about just casting
it and having people
play multiple parts that
underlines that.
ALAN SEALES: So
did you cast based
on overall look and pirouette
and singing ability?
I mean--
KELLY DEVINE: It all
started with the dancing.
ALAN SEALES: Everybody
bring your tap shoes.
IAN EISENDRATH: Dancing first,
anything else is a bonus.
KELLY DEVINE: Everything
else is secondary, I'm sorry.
IRENE SANKOFF: You know,
I think for me a lot of it
came out immediately the first
song that they would sing
is "Welcome to the Rock."
And Ian would say, so
you can count us in?
And then just seeing how
easy we're with counting in,
or if they were like, oh me,
or what, you know what I mean?
Like, it just--
that told me a lot.
I don't know about you
guys, but because we
were kind of like in
the dark a little bit,
being like we don't
really know what we need,
we kind of know how many we
need, we kind of know ages,
but that can switch.
So there was nothing
really solid,
except for a sense of
being willing to play
and a sense of sort of a
selflessness, like an openness.
I mean--
IAN EISENDRATH: We knew we
were forming an ensemble.
It's important to find a
group of really strong actors
that we knew would be willing
to play well together.
KELLY DEVINE: And
then the essence
of some of the characters,
of the real life people
that would find the
story too, I think--
not that they had to be a
doppelganger or anything
like that, but just the
essence of who that person is
and be able to sort of
embrace that and embody it.
DAVID HEIN: And that's and
that's tricky sometimes,
because all of the
characters on stage
are amalgamations
and composites.
To tell that many stories
in such a short a time,
we've had to sort of
compress these stories,
compress these characters.
So often, we're
seeing these friends
that we made out a
new film and we're
trying to represent three
of them through one person.
And while we're not
doing a documentary,
we're still trying
to find who's going
to represent them properly.
ALAN SEALES: The most
compelling stories.
Yeah, there's one that
really stands out for me.
Jenn plays this character,
Captain Beverley Bass, right,
who is the first female
pilot to ever make captain
at American Airlines,
just happened
to be piloting one of these 38
planes that landed in Gander.
And one of my favorite
songs in the show
is actually her song
singing about this.
So Jenn, would you
mind spontaneously--
we didn't rehearse this at all--
singing this for us?
JENN COLELLA: Oh, exactly.
Very welcome.
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
JENN COLELLA: Thank you.
[MUSIC - COME FROM AWAY ORIGINAL
BROADWAY CAST, "ME AND THE SKY"]
ALAN SEALES: So
I've been on stage
with Broadway performances now.
That's pretty cool.
Yay, me.
The characters that you
guys found and discovered,
I mean, Beverly,
Captain Beverly, right,
Captain Bass, just one
of many amazing things.
There was also-- I
mean, she's from,
I guess her home
base is from Texas,
and then there's also
the Texan woman who
fell in love with
the British man
because they happened
to be on the same plane.
And then there was another
person who actually had--
played by Q, who has a
son that was a volunteer
firefighter, or actually a--
IRENE SANKOFF: Firefighter.
ALAN SEALES: --straight
actual firefighter that--
can we give that--
I guess lost his life in 9/11.
So like you were spending
the whole show wondering
what happened to your son.
All these characters
that you found,
is there anybody that
you have left out
that you wish you could
have told their story?
IRENE SANKOFF: Yeah, absolutely.
You know, as much as possible
we amalgamated as many things
as we could.
I mean David always talks about
how the pharmacist for instance
at the Shoppers
Drug Mart was just
all night trying to
figure out how to refill
people's prescriptions.
And we had a whole
scene at one point,
but now it's just down to
one line in the town scene
where they say Martin O'Brien,
or no, it's not Martin--
DAVID HEIN: Dr.
O'Brien is filling
pharmacies' prescriptions
from around the world.
We tried to keep every single
story we could in there.
There was a story about
the air traffic controllers
who had nothing to do, so
they just made chili nonstop.
And that used to be
more fleshed out,
and now it's just one of our
characters coming out saying,
Bonnie, I made some chili.
But what's amazing is when
the people actually come--
we've had air traffic
controllers come,
and they're like,
you've gotten the chili!
IRENE SANKOFF: Yes, we did.
DAVID HEIN: And
so we tried to get
every single story we
possibly could in there, even
if it's just a little line.
ALAN SEALES: The one
character that I guess the--
talking about her human
children and her real children
at the beginning, obviously like
against security orders, right?
Like she was technically
not allowed to by the FAA,
went into the cargo hold
and found all these animals,
got the cats and dogs and
even bonobo chimps that
were stuck in the cargo
hold and weren't allowed
to come off the plane, because
people when they got off
were only allowed to take
their carry ons, that was it.
IRENE SANKOFF: Yep.
ALAN SEALES: So their
cargo, including pets,
were stuck on the planes.
And other than-- is there
anything along those lines that
just didn't make it in,
or that you wish you
could have fleshed out more?
Like, why cut it down to 100
minutes in the first place?
DAVID HEIN: Well, so it
was originally longer.
The first draft that we wrote
was about five hours long
and they still hadn't
gotten off the plane.
So we had a lot to do.
But--
ALAN SEALES: After
all the movies.
"Titanic" five times.
Right.
I think-- and
there were stories.
Like, there's this wonderful
story about a local
who was sitting down
by the water and one
of the-- not a local,
a come from away--
who was sitting down there.
And one of the locals came
up and said, are you OK?
And they said, I could
use a cup of coffee.
I just really miss my dog.
And the local went
away and came back
with a cup of coffee and
their dog and was like here,
if you need some dog time.
And just amazing stories, and we
just couldn't fit them all in.
Part of the reason we kept
it compact so much we,
originally had an intermission
and then one of our producers--
we've got this amazing producing
team, Junkyard Dog productions.
And they actually
said to us that there
was no chance during it for
anyone from the town, anyone
from away to like step out of
the moment and have a drink
and go to the bathroom and say,
how do you think it's going?
I don't know.
How do you think
it's going, right?
So we wanted to really
take the audience
into that experience with us.
And it's something that you
start at the beginning and you
don't--
it doesn't let up until
the until the end.
And so we just had to fit
every story we could in there.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I commented
on that with the friend
that I went with
to see the show.
Because as soon as the
lights go down, usually
with your traditional show,
you've got the overture
and then the curtain stays
down and you're like getting
settled.
Everyone is pulling
out their cell phones
and switching them to
Airplane mode and everything--
no pun Intended .
But in this show, like lights go
down and it's like three beats,
and then boom,
everyone's on stage
and they kick off
"Welcome to the Rock."
And I'm just like,
OK, here I go.
And you're right,
it was just nonstop.
Even the dialogue is
kept up the same pace
that the songs keep
up, and it's very
touching to-- so kudos to them.
No question there, just making
a very, very great statement.
So throwing it into the cast a
little bit, of the characters
that you portray,
have any of you
met your actual
people that you do?
You all have?
Who's?
JENN COLELLA: Captain Beverley
Bass and I are good friends.
She's seen the show
just over 60 times.
She's been to all
of those cities.
She brought 90 female
pilots to our opening
in Toronto, 50 female
pilots in Seattle.
And she and Tom,
her husband, have
been very present throughout
the whole experience,
so it's been cool
to get to know her.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
Well anybody else?
Did you guys keep in touch?
SHARON WHEATLEY:
Nick and Diane, who
Lee McDougall and I
portray, is the British oil
executive in the Texas--
they call her a housewife,
but she's elevated.
She was actually a buyer.
She had like a real career.
But they are the ones who met.
And Nick and Diane actually
really did marry in real life.
And they've seen the show.
They're in competition
with Beverly.
They're behind,
they'll tell you.
But Beverly also gets free
airfare, so there's that.
They've come.
They've come quite a bit.
They are very lovely.
We caught them the other
day out signing autographs.
It's a full experience for them.
For all the characters,
it's really wonderful.
I was like, hey,
get out of here!
ALAN SEALES: This is mine.
ASTRID VAN WIEREN: My character
is a composite of two women,
and representing a lot
of women in Gander.
My main character
is Beulah Davis,
who is a combination of
Beulah Cooper and Diane Davis.
And I got to meet them when we
went to Gander, to do our two
concerts there at the world's
largest walk in refrigerator.
And we had a
reception beforehand,
before they even saw
the show we met them.
And Beulah and I were wearing
almost the exact same outfit
That was a nice
confirmation that we were--
and Diane was actually wearing
exactly the same red that
was in both of our
outfits, so the three of us
had a good giggle about that.
And they're incredible
women and Facebook friends,
and they've been now to New
York and they were there
for our opening.
We got to bring all our
people, or our doppelgangers,
or partners on the
stage with us and, they
got to experience
that bow and all that
love that we get every night
after the show coming at us.
W got to share that with them,
so that was pretty incredible.
ALAN SEALES: Interesting.
CAESAR SAMAYOA: Jenn and
I both the play a couple.
We're a couple that are both
named Kevin in the show.
And Right after
the La Jolla run,
I'm sitting and
checking my email
and I see one of the emails pop
up that says, my name's Kevin,
and I hear you're
playing me in a musical.
And we've become
amazing friends.
We've all met.
This is something.
CHAD KIMBALL: My Kevin was
more involved in the process.
They did breakup, but he was
there for the La Jolla opening.
I don't think Kevin J was,
but-- well, he wasn't.
But they came to
Seattle, both of them.
SPEAKER 3: It's just the facts.
CHAD KIMBALL: Yeah,
just the facts, buys.
I'm giving you a timeline here.
And But Kevin T, my Kevin--
I have nothing against you--
I wrote a book called
Channel of Your Peace.
And so he was just
here, actually.
He just left the other day.
We had dinner, and he's hoping
to get his book out there,
called Channel of Your Peace
ALAN SEALES: Channel of Peace.
CHAD KIMBALL: Channel of Peace?
Obviously I've read it.
Jeez, I'm just going
to not say anything.
CAESAR SAMAYOA: My Kevin's
book will be out soon, too.
And Robin, his new
assistant, his book
will be out after theirs.
ALAN SEALES: Can we
pause for one second?
If anybody has
audience questions,
we only have one mic
this time unfortunately,
because of all these mics.
So everyone line up over here
while we continue our stories.
All right.
Rodney, are you going
to say something?
Oh, you good?
JOEL HATCH: I met Claude
Elliott, the mayor of Gander,
in Seattle.
And I was a little nervous
the first time I met him.
And I said, I don't think I'm a
very precise duplicate of you.
He said, well, you
don't have hair.
But he said, just so
you tell the story
right, that's all I care.
And he was great.
He was just wonderful,
and he's been
a big supporter of the show.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Q, I'm curious about
your connection,
because for someone who actually
lost somebody during all this,
is it hard for her
or do you know,
it is more of in memoriam
of what she went through,
or does she prefer to see
it or not see it, or do you
know at all?
Q SMITH: Well, our writers
have actually more experience.
They've actually been to her
home and met her entire family.
I've met her twice, and
we all met her, actually.
And she loved the show.
She loved the show.
And on opening night, she gave
me a replicate of Kevin's badge
with his face on
it, and a relic.
And it was so special.
And she and we, you know, we're
both pretty spiritual people.
We have a strong faith and
we know that there's always
a sunnier side to things.
Unfortunately, she went
through this tragic situation.
She found so Much hope
and peace in the show.
And she's thankful.
She's thankful for it.
ALAN SEALES: OK.
Question?
AUDIENCE: My name's
Ashley, and I've actually
already seen the show.
Loved it, can't stop
talking about it.
I already have tickets
to see it again.
I think you're all fabulous.
So I was sitting here trying to
think of what I would ask you,
and I keep going back to exactly
how much toilet paper did
they bring to the Lion's Club?
IRENE SANKOFF: I
think the quote we
got was enough to last a
year for Gander Academy.
It was actually, I
want to say-- no,
where did they drop
it off in real life?
Because I know we
switch things around,
because it's not a documentary,
it's a piece of theater.
So we tried to
amalgamate, think about--
DAVID HEIN: This
is the Lion's Club.
IRENE SANKOFF: This
is the Lion's club.
Yes.
KELLY DEVINE: So Janice, you
should explain that line,
just so you get a
little background.
KENDRA KASSEBAUM: Right.
So I play a reporter whose it's
the first day on the job when
all of this is happening.
And so her job was to kind of
get the information out there,
what people need and everything.
And she just put out there that
I we just need a little toilet
paper over at the Lions
Club, if you got any extra.
And so she's back on the air
saying for the love of God,
stop bringing toilet
paper to the Lions Club.
So that's where that comes from.
DAVID HEIN: And it
really happened.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm
Joanna, and I'm Canadian,
so I'm so excited to see
a story about Canada,
but also curious about
how you opened in Toronto
and how you got your
start in Toronto
and then came to New York,
because that feels almost
like the opposite of shows
usually opening broadly here
and then going on the road.
IRENE SANKOFF: It is.
It is, actually, yeah.
DAVID HEIN: So we started
at Sheridan College,
with something called the
Canadian Music Theater Project.
So all of these
experienced actors
are having to play characters
that were originally
based on students.
We worked with students there,
and also at Goodspeed Musicals.
And students have
a lot of energy,
and they jump from
thing to thing,
and they're happy
to move chairs.
And so these guys have to
put up with a show that
was based on that.
I think what we've
learned along the way
is that as Canadians
ourselves, it's definitely
this wonderful Canadian story
that we feel a lot of pride in.
There was 200 planes
diverted across the country,
not only to Gander but also
out on the west coast and all
over the place.
But it's also, as
New Yorkers, it's
people who are here
in New York, there's
this sense that it's an
American story, as well.
It's an additional memory
to what happened on 9/11.
And everyone we've talked
to, Hannah's family,
but also when we're
in Washington, D.C.,
we spoke to a lot
of the survivors
and the survivors'
families there.
We've talked to--
our first preview was
for the FDNY Foundation here.
And what they told us was
that what happened in Gander
was a tribute to the people
that they lost, that it was not
a replacement memory, but an
additional memory and a glimmer
of hope on such a tragic day.
So I think it's
important for them.
And beyond that,
what we've realized
is that it's really an
international story.
It was something that happened
to the world at the same time,
and that we all had reactions
to it, wherever you were from.
And that sort of coalesced
for us in the story of Gander,
because so many people
were from around the world.
So it expanded beyond there.
We've also had an
amazing team who's
supported the show, this
little Canadian show
and has brought it to the world.
And we've been
really blessed to be
able to share this with as
many people as possible.
We have a team that
I think originally
wasn't sure whether
this was a Broadway
show but knew that it was
an important story to tell
and has supported it
all along the way.
IAN EISENDRATH: And
one of the gifts
that I think our producers
gave us, often shows
are go as quickly as
possible to get to New York.
They gave us the gift of time
and multiple productions,
and we didn't just
rush to New York.
The goal was not just
to have a Broadway show,
but to really explore
the story and tell it
in the most truthful,
honoring, and effective way.
And I think playing
Canada, playing La Jolla,
playing Seattle, playing
D.C., which was directly
impacted by 9/11, all
these different cities
and listening to those
audiences helped all of us
hone everything, from the
writing to the staging
to the music to the production.
RODNEY HICKS: And it
gave us a real journey,
a familial journey of coming
together amongst ourselves
and this bond that we have.
ALAN SEALES: So
other than the rent,
did anything change
about the show
going from Toronto to New York?
IRENE SANKOFF: Yes.
KELLY DEVINE: Yeah.
Yeah, a lot.
IRENE SANKOFF: We
added a new song.
ALAN SEALES: Did you?
IRENE SANKOFF: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: What was new?
IRENE SANKOFF: Hannah's song.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, nice.
Yeah.
That song is new.
IRENE SANKOFF: Expanded.
DAVID HEIN: We continued to
tweak and tighten and cut.
You know, it's funny.
Working with the same
team over so many cities
within the theater,
it felt very safe.
We were all just
doing what we do.
We were just making the show
as good as we possibly could.
It was only when you go out
the door that you're like,
oh my god, it's Broadway.
What's--
IAN EISENDRATH: Well, I
feel like one of the things
that changed with the
show is that you guys kept
interviewing people, and
they kept meeting people.
That's why we got a new song.
And it's such a credit
to them as writers.
They could have made
up phenomenal stories.
They were so committed
to capturing the truth.
And once they spent a good
amount of time with Hannah,
suddenly a song flowed out
of them and we have that.
So it's been an
interesting process.
KELLY DEVINE: I
have to add, too,
that our director, Chris
Ashley pushed all of us
at every moment relentlessly.
IRENE SANKOFF: Relentlessly.
KELLY DEVINE: Never stopped.
To the very last second
before we opened.
DAVID HEIN: I think last night
I actually got a note via text.
IRENE SANKOFF: I blocked
his email address.
KELLY DEVINE: He really
had such a good insight
to what you guys
wanted, and he sort of
set us on the right path.
And then he just wouldn't
accept anything that
was just slightly undercooked.
Sometimes when you're
really on a tight schedule
and you got to open
something, it's easy to go,
you know what, that's fine.
Let's keep going, it's working.
But that wasn't ever acceptable.
We always had to
go deeper, which
I think is why we are
up here, because I think
we've done something
that we're proud of,
that we took a long,
long time to cultivate.
ALAN SEALES: All
right, to wrap up here,
after people see
the show, what's
the one thing that you hope
people take away with them when
they leave?
DAVID HEIN: There's
a Mr. Rogers quote
that we like to
talk about, which
is that when his mom said when
he saw something scary on TV,
his mother used to tell him,
if you see something scary,
always look for the helpers.
There's always
goodness in the world.
There's always-- and
that doesn't often
doesn't get the focus.
And it feels
particularly right now
when we're often feeling
divided against each other,
it's important to look for
stories that bring us together,
to focus on the people
who are helping.
There's always more helpers
than there are people who
are perpetrating these acts.
And it feels important to stick
it in your search bar every day
and find those things that
remind us that there's
goodness in the world.
That's what I keep
coming back to.
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
IRENE SANKOFF: Yeah, I
think about at the end
of the year, last
year, 2016, there
was that video that was put
together because everyone
was like, see you later, 2016.
But there was like oh, but--
like you go through this
thing where it was like,
PS, but this happened in 2016,
and we accomplished this.
And it just sort of--
I mean, it sounds really trite
to say look on the bright side,
but it's not.
It's more where you choose to
put your energy and your focus,
and I think that
does affect what
you put out into the world.
I do.
And so it's much the same thing.
DAVID HEIN: Yeah, it's been
good for us to tell the story
and be able to
live in the story.
I think it's been good for
all of us to be celebrating
these people out of
Newfoundland, to be celebrating
the goodness that they
created and the friendships
that they created.
It feels like every
day we're living
in the shadow of
something terrible,
and it feels important to
find the pockets of good.
IAN EISENDRATH: Well said.
PETRINA BROMLEY: I
just want to add,
I'm actually from
Newfoundland myself.
And as a member of the cast
on a very personal level
to be involved with this show,
people come to me all the time
after the show who have come
from Newfoundland to see it.
And the kind of
pride that happens
and the smiles and the
pleasure on people's faces
just gives me an extra
added bonus of joy
in this show, because
we don't toot our horns
enough in Canada, and
especially in Newfoundland.
So for me, I get
that extra joy on top
of what they're talking about.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
the soundtrack
came out yesterday, yeah?
DAVID HEIN: Today, I think.
Today is our day.
ALAN SEALES: Physically today.
I think it was a digital
download yesterday.
DAVID HEIN: Cast album, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I was looking
for it on Google Play Music.
All right.
DAVID HEIN: Dude.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
Gerald Schoenfeld--
Schoenfeld, did
I say that right?
The Gerald Schoenfeld
Theater, 236 West 45th.
Wecomefromaway on
Twitter and Instagram.
Wecomefromaway.com.
Everybody here, don't
forget our ticket discount.
Please see the show.
Help me give them another
round of applause.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
DAVID HEIN: Nice.
That's great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]